Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this will be
my flash movie video for the alternate ending
alternate post credit scenes there was a bunch
of Henry Cavill super in they cut out of the
movie I know there's lots of questions about what
happened to Grant gustin's flash Cameo scene from
the DCTV Universe don't worry I'll explain all
that as well as reverse flash if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos and careful for spoilers if you have
not seen the movie yet because we'll be talking
about everything to explain what they cut out of
the movie just starting at the beginning of the
movie and we'll do all the deleted scenes in the
order that they would have appeared in the movie
there were a completely alternate opening scene
featuring Henry cavill's Superman Ben Affleck's
Batman Alfred even some deleted scenes of Wonder
Woman this is the original full version of that
scene yeah I have to go to work uh three minutes
ago and sorry I'm in sort of a rush for the
sandwich you can't rush a good sandwich dude
we have a situation at Gotham General
a robbery gone wrong this is the middle
of the morning why is our bat friend even
awake call Superman that was my first thought
ever about her I'm sorry is
my sandwich ready I learned
my lesson on the boat last year's
stuff my sister comes out with me
she's drunk personal comments about my
mom's friends as well which I think is
we eating that candy bar maybe you could throw it
to me hi Bruce yes I'm coming the funny thing is
they included some of that in all the trailers
like there are a lot of deleted scenes in the
trailers you may have spotted they had the funny
scene of him in the shop in Central City getting
ready to go to work trying to get his food like
give me the PB J because he needs so many calories
but then there's a bunch of Justice League
problems all over the Earth so all the different
members of the Justice League are handling things
and they have a funny moment with him trying to
decide which one to go help like which problem
is the worst should I go help Superman trying to
stop this volcano kind of seems like he has that
Under Wraps Batman calls him through Alfred needs
him in Gotham City the reason why they got rid of
this and they just started with his take off is
they just wanted a more action-packed opening
and they sort of stopped short there's just a
couple funny moments where things slow down right
here at the beginning and they wanted a quicker
opening where they go straight to the hospital
save and Ben Affleck Batman's chase scene there
were a couple completely alternate versions of
the movie that they had before they settled on
doing a version of Flashpoint or doing a version
of Michael Keaton's Batman originally when the
first few directors were hired on after Batman v
Superman came out and they first announced they
were releasing a flash Solo movie this was the
original release schedule we would have seen the
movie back in 2018 back then they weren't going
to do a version of Flashpoint the main villains
would have been the flash Rogues like Captain
Cold Heatwave mirror Master Captain Boomerang
of the DC EU there wasn't going to be any time
traveling Iris West would have been a bigger
character and even though reverse flash wouldn't
have been the main villain of this first movie he
would have still been a much bigger character than
he was in the current version of the theatrical
cut that you see now this movie did have a
lot of reverse flash in it that they cut out
I've got a separate video coming about him just
because he's such a huge character to The Flash
and they got big plans for him for the future of
the flash even though Ezra Miller probably going
to be recast but the director Andy muschietti
very literally posted a reverse flash picture
on his Instagram and then confirmed a couple of
days ago oh yeah reverse flash definitely killed
Barry's Mother originally his cut of the movie
was four hours long so just a lot of it wound
up hitting The Cutting Room floor thus reverse
flash hit The Cutting Room floor basically the
next big deleted scenes were when they first meet
Michael Keaton's Batman and he starts explaining
what really happened to him after the events of
Batman Returns this is a version of the scene that
they released online a guy called Superman who
can stop soda yeah and flies shoots lasers out
of his eyes yes he flies and he shoots lasers
out of his eyes yes no one said Superman that
might be a little on the nose you call yourself
Batman yeah I don't call myself super bad man
what you're doing here it's dinner Swain
is Batman really not So Much Anymore
you know didn't really need me things have changed
Gotham's now one of the safest cities in the world
I I need you we need you in my timeline Batman's
our strategist our our leader the world needs
Superman you're the best detective in the world
you're probably the only person who can help me
find him so will you help us okay they confirmed
that there's a much longer deleted scene version
of this that'll be on the Blu-ray when that comes
out so we will get to see it with Michael Keaton's
Batman giving a much longer explanation of what
really happened after Batman Returns a much
greater detail and why he stopped being Batman
in the theatrical version that we saw he kind of
brushes past it like well Gotham save the city in
the world they don't need me anymore there are a
couple other smaller deleted scenes and character
moments with Michael Keaton's Batman just talking
with Barry about his past and it was meant to
dovetail with the more Flashpoint comic story of
both Batman's backstories being relatively similar
like his backstory being similar to Ben Affleck
Batman's backstory at one point they had thought
about doing a version of Jeffrey Dean Morgan as a
version of Flashpoint Batman but when they found
out that they were going to get Michael Keaton
they just got rid of that story the next one was
when they go to rescue Supergirl in the middle
of the movie there were a bunch of deleted scenes
of their actual fight scene and Escape primarily
Super Girls fight against the Russians Sasha
Kaye claims that they cut this because it got
way too rated R way too Homeland unless you went
full homelander on all the Russians popping them
all like a bunch of Flesh balloons I don't think
they're gonna put these in the Blu-ray because
they were so hardcore they wanted to keep the
movie PG-13 but she said their whole Escape scene
at The Silo she called it The Silo but it was that
Russian prison that she was stuck in went on for
way way longer there were also more scenes like
that deleted scenes that were way too hardcore
and R-rated during their final fight against the
kryptonians mostly Super Girls Death Scenes when
Zod and other kryptonians kept killing her that
were way more graphic and the Flash's takedowns
of the kryptonians wound up being a little more
graphic there was a little more hand vibrating
through kryptonians if you get my meaning slightly
stabbier versions of both of the flashes then the
next major deleted scenes like way bigger were
the actual Multiverse cameos after dark flash
appears and the Multiverse starts to collapse
on itself they said that they actually did way
more Cameo scenes than just wound up hitting The
Cutting Room floor because the movie went on for
too long the ones that they've revealed so far are
a cut scene of Marlon Brando's jorel he would have
also been on Christopher Reeve Superman's Earth
than an Adam West Universe they would have also
included scenes of Burgess Meredith's penguin his
version of The Joker they had the Joker's laugh
from his universe but when you see Adam West
Batman you just hear his laugh they would have
included Linda Carter's Wonder Woman in her own
Universe she would have been in one of the other
Chronicles with the different colors they were all
meant to be the Green Lantern spectrum of emotions
those were the colors that they were going with it
did sound like they had more plans for DCTV Grant
Gustin related Multiverse Cameo scenes but I think
it was a combination of scheduling problems that
prevented that as well as the whole way that they
conceived and pulled off these Multiverse Cameo
scenes which is one of my complaints against the
movie Just The Way They visualized the Multiverse
they used one really weird sketchy CG but also the
whole concept of the Chrono bowls I feel like the
way the Flash TV show depicted the Multiverse was
way better so like the crisis on infinite Earth's
crossover scene with Ezra Miller's flash wound up
being way better than what they did in The Flash
movie with all the The Cameo scenes there were
probably some other Multiverse Cameo scenes here
that they cut but the director hasn't revealed all
of them yet then there was a much much longer very
very different ending in post-credit scenes that
were meant to set up a movie version of crisis
on infant Earth and a new version of the Justice
League as part of the new 10-year plan that they
developed so this is what Henry Cavill was talking
about when he said that much much more was on the
way after that Black Adam Superman post-credits
scene this was before Jane's gonna have been hired
and they'd essentially kind of pushed him to the
side during the ending when Barry switches the
can of tomatoes to help free his father it makes
the final change of the timeline but small enough
that things aren't as bad as they were before
what was going to happen when he stepped out of
the courthouse it was still going to be the DC
EU but a slightly different retuned DC EU like
it still would have been the Schneider verse
instead of seeing George Clooney's Batman in
the scene stepping out of the Mercedes in the
original version he was going to see Supergirl
floating down they included a version of that
deleted scene in the trailer is where she asked
him are you ready and you can see Batman's
Mercedes Maybach the courthouse steps behind
her Michael Keaton's Batman would have been the
Batman to step out of the Mercedes you probably
saw the behind the scenes of them filming this a
long time ago this is him on the courthouse steps
with Barry during this scene of them celebrating
his father getting out of prison Wonder Woman and
Henry Cavill Superman both wearing their civilian
clothes in their disguises like Diana Prince
and Clark Kent disguises would have shown up to
celebrate with them and because this was a result
of Barry changing the timeline a little bit again
now Supergirl and Keaton's Batman were on this
main Earth and the other Justice League characters
weren't aware of the changes till Barry told them
what he did so Michael Keaton's Batman would have
been the de facto main Batman for crossover movies
until crisis on infinite Earths in the movies so
the idea is that because the timeline had changed
Henry Cavill Superman had always known Supergirl
and she'd always been on this Earth there would
have been a post-credit scene where they share a
scene together like Superman is Supergirl but then
Barry also has a dream in a post-credit scenes
and during it Ben Affleck's Batman was going
to warn him of a coming crisis teasing crisis on
infinite herbs that would have been their Avengers
end game Thanos kind of teaser like at the end of
the first Avengers movie they would have also set
up a live-action Batman Beyond movie for Michael
Keaton's Batman they're not doing that anymore
because of James Gunn's reboot of the dceu that's
also why they changed the post-credits scene and
changed the ending as well to make it more
ambiguous so is George Clooney's Batman and
they make it seem like Ezra Miller's flash is now
stuck in that alternate universe in the Clooney
verse they would have gone on to do Justice League
two and set that up with this version of Michael
Keaton's Batman in reverse flash would have been
one of the bigger villains of The Flash 2 sequel
until obviously all the trouble with Ezra Miller
happened and that was also kind of wrapped up in
the James guns reboot like we'll tie a bow on this
and kind of put it over in its own little Universe
there's a bunch more deleted scenes that they cut
so we'll probably learn about those over the next
couple weeks is there any big ones besides like
reverse flash I'll do separate videos about that
my reverse flash video should to be up in the next
couple of days there's also a bunch of trailers
coming from Netflix today like avatar The Last
Airbender Netflix supposed to release a trailer
a one-piece Netflix trailer so I'll try to do
videos for all that stuff this weekend too and
the other big thing that's happening next week is
Marvel's secret Invasion episode one is dropping
I'll be doing weekly episode videos just like
all the other Marvel Disney plus Series so I'll
link those Below in the description click here
for my flash movie post credit scene video and
click here for my full breakdown of the entire
movie with all the Easter eggs and references
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!